[Musique]
bienvenue sur tv 78 pour cette nouvelle
édition de l'entretien politique nous
partons aujourd'hui pour la petite
commune de watteville surnom cyan son
maire stéphane jeanne est avec nous
bonjour bonjour vous êtes à la tête de
ce village d'un peu plus de 1000
habitants et ce depuis 2014 c'est donc
votre deuxième mandat alors pour cité
située pardon - ville cela se trouve
dans le canton de limay dans le parc
naturel régional du vexin français
quand on est maire d'une petite commune
rurale quelle est la priorité en ce
moment en cette période de crise
sanitaire et économique
économiquement on a une petite commune
sans trop de d'entreprise par contre on
a quand même à des commerçants donc tout
la possibilité tout ce qu'il y en a pas
ce qui était pour qu'on puisse accéder à
ces commerces
donc ce niveau là ça pose pas de
problème et ont fait respecter les
gestes derrière londres 10 jours du
marché et après c'est une organisation
donc à l'école entre services de cantine
pas plus tard que ce midi en train de
faire le service y ont fait des tours 9
heures entre les élus et réadapter les
horaires du personnel pour pouvoir
assurer dans les meilleures des sciences
sanitaires en fonction des directives
qu'on a reçu
la restauration de nos enfants voilà
donc ça passe par au lieu de 1 servent
au service d'une heure on a fait quatre
services d'une heure donc en séparant
les salles et donc faut du personnel en
plus et et on a mis les élus à
contribution voilà et puis mince occuper
nos personnages et aussi qu'ils sont
isolés ou encore dernièrement une
personne qui est resté trois jours
allongée chez elle et tous les
dispositifs qu'on a pu mettre en place
et ça va
l'histoire se termine jamais pu être
pire et donc les élus interviennent sur
le terrain vous vous le disiez vous même
vous étiez encore à la cantine ce midi
cantine scolaire
oui voilà et hier on a fait aussi dans
la région nous envoyer un bus test
coville 58 personnes qui sont venues se
faire tester et la grande difficulté
actuellement c'est d'orienter nos
administrés faire les centres de test et
surtout vers les centres de vaccination
c'est que là c'est je dirais même très
compliqué donc entre les problèmes de
salles ouvertes ou pas ouverte et pas
que ça arrivait ou pas arrivé donc on
essaie de s'adapter enfin moi tous les
jeudis soirs avec la rs en
visioconférence en suivant volé il ya le
site internet quand on a des infos et je
suis nos journaux qui sortent tous les
deux mois en terme de contexte si on a
vu ces derniers mois beaucoup de
citadins de parisiens aussi revenir
s'installer dans des plus petites villes
à la campagne
vous l'avez constaté déjà est-ce qu'il
ya vous avez un retour ou des demandes
de population qui souhaitait s'installer
dans votre commune on a beaucoup de
jeunes qui viennent qui sont demande à
toutes les ventes qui se sont récemment
son cd jeunes qui arrivent avec des
jeunes enfants soient des mamans
enceintes qui nous arrange bien pour la
pérennité de notre école et c'est vrai
qu'il produit en vente actuellement
avons un bilan laisse pas longtemps si
son juste prix je peux vous dire que ça
part très très rapidement ou en ville
qui fait partie d'une agglomération
c'est celle de grand paris seine et oise
gps au 73 communes
est ce que c'est un atout est ce que
c'est un handicap pour une commune comme
la vôtre
est ce que vous êtes noyé au milieu de
cette agglomération
ça ne nous faire entendre mais le jeu
yakin ya des inconvénients bien sûr il
ya quand même des atouts aussi sur
l'apport qu'on peut avoir des services
extérieurs et en comités de communes
ainsi arrêté lui après la communauté
d'agglomération avec mol en ligne auront
d'autres commençaient à faire certains
projets qui restait à des petites
échelles de rentrer sur les transferts
de compétences assez énorme et le plus
difficile mais c'est la voirie va pas se
le cacher mais bon espoir qu'un jour on
y arrive et que tout ça se met en place
mais bon c'est notre cinquième n 6 a
mené dès janvier 2016 on est entré en
politique mène donc c'est vrai c'est une
grosse machine donc pas trop le choix
fallait y aller et puis voilà on a
récupéré quelques compétences comme la
petite enfance l'enfance ce qu'avait été
transféré de l'acuité de la
collaboration avec harel mais on
s'adapte aussi et puis par contre on
sait sur des avantages sur certaines de
certaines compétences entre le transport
entre autres acquis il ya des choses
qu'on croit affaire est classée il
pourquoi pas faire chez eux
je disais tout à l'heure c'est votre
deuxième mandat et quelle est votre
priorité pour ce deuxième mandat et puis
qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé motivé
peut-être à repartir pour quelques
nouvelles années on sait pour quatrième
mandat j'étais sûr de mes quatrièmes
excusez moi je vais oublier quelques uns
j'ai été lus en cours de mandat 2005 a
élu en 2008 et 2014 et 2020 bas
après là c'est que des produits frais
pas concrétisé en 2019 qui ont fait un
peu que je voulais repartir pour les
concrétiser
qu'ils vont arriver bientôt est
normalement si tout va bien ma prochain
d'avoir enfin à l'ouverture de cette
supérette voilà et puis elle aussi la
rénovation de notre mairie ont terminé
de travaux et maintenant aussi mois
prochain devraient faire leur expulsion
définitive de tous les corps de métier
donc et puis de mettre une nouvelle
équipe en place
on s'est un peu mais la motivation est
toujours là parce que on a d'autres
projets mais un moment ça il va falloir
penser à s'arrêter passer la main parce
que je ne suis aperçu des projets on
aura tout le temps j'ai en tout cas il y
en a dix c'est que je pense j'ai pris du
plaisir bon à savoir quel âge quand même
entre la deuxième et la troisième
élection je suis reparti avec la même
équipe
13 sur 15 donc là je repars avec deux
tiers de nouveau donc une opposition de
personnes dans opposé avec mais bon ça
se passe bien et puis un flottement de
vrai qu'il arrive à notre insu et à une
situation évidente
pas évident de se réunir j'évite de
penser qu'une histoire souvent avec eux
de kobe c'est l'heure pour nous de
commencer à le faire à nouveau la
communication l'environnement sur les
commissions aucun de la vision mais
c'est vrai que rien de présentiel non
réquisitionnées salle des fêtes pour
faire nos réunions à 15 et puis faire
avancer les dossiers
en tout cas je voulais dire il ya un
moment qui sera important c'est le 8
mars c'est dans à peu près un mois il y
aura le départ tout cas la deuxième
étape plutôt du paris-nice qui partira
donc deux moins ville de votre commune
comment vous préparer cet événement ce
sera une première pour la ville c'est un
grand rendez vous on l'espère avec un
petit peu de public comment vous
préparez ce moment bon on ne prépare
l'école département et sow ont ça
s'avance un lien vous beaucoup de deux
choses à faire mais on a quand même
d'incertitude de scoville à ce qu'on va
le faire avec son public
on sait qu'on va reconduire toutes les
mesures sanitaires qui se sont faits au
niveau 2 du tour de france donc on s'est
compliqué mais on va remettre a obligé
de s'adapter la date butoir qu'on va
donner si le 25 février pour savoir si
ce sera avec ou sans public
donc on part sur deux organisations avec
ou sans public et à décharge sera pas le
même mais il faut quand même qu'on
avance pour conférer aux eaux plus
défavorable pour l'organisation s'est
allié au niveau de nos bénévoles et tous
et de recevoir du public ce qu'on espère
parce que ça c'est un peu dommage de le
louper cette opportunité ça faisait 5 6
ans j'étais candidat j'ai porté la
candidature de la commune de oignies
pour pour ce départ de la deuxième étape
de paris-nice communes rurales
car bédié le plus jeune qui partement
hector prud'homme directeur d'aso bon
c'est vrai un peu déçu si on pouvait pas
le verlan de conditions n'étant pas
qu'ils la directrice tout à l'heure on a
parlé pour l'organisation et puis voici
on peut pas faire une belle fête mais on
attend surtout que 5 des loyers alors à
cette date pour voir les charges
définitif le 25 février et on vous
souhaite d'avoir du public pour ce 8
mars date de départ de la deuxième étape
du paris nice la veille pour la première
étape ce sera du côté de saint cyr
l'école toujours dans les yvelines merci
beaucoup et stéphane jeunes d'avoir été
avec nous pour cet entretien politique
l'occasion de faire un focus sur une
petite commune du département des
yvelines où un vil surnom cyan merci à
vous et on se retrouve bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]